les dépanneurs les stations service sont
au nombre des commerces essentielles qui
sont restés ouverts depuis le début de
la crise
allez bouchard et fondateur et président
exécutif du conseil de couche tard il
était avec nous ce soir bonsoir monsieur
bouchard rejoint cette vision ma dutil
il ya pas très longtemps sur nos ondes
de rdi économie nous disait nous on a
des activités en roumanie et ont grâce à
l'expérience qu'on a eu là bas on a pu
mieux se préparer à la coved 19 quand
c'est arrivé au québec
est ce que vous vous magasins en norvège
vous permettent de faire ça aussi
oui effectivement on ne peut plus vivre
ce qui s'est passé au danemark en
norvège en irlande
on s'est préparés lorsque lorsqu'on me
venir là que vit ici on voyait qu'il est
les gens étaient optimistes et couailhac
en en or ce serait mineur ici mais avec
ce qu'on voyait nous en europe ont pensé
que ça arriverait et plus sérieusement
alors on s'est approvisionné de deux
acren de purell de masques etc alors
même malgré cette précaution l'aspect
pas suffisant c'était pas suffisant donc
vous vous étiez préparé meilleur fff à
lui encore en faire davantage a fallu
que j'aille en or à boire vraiment
comment ça se passait sur les lieux on
ne disait mais on a toujours on écoute
aussi ce que nos gentils jc nous ici il
y avait trop de discours se souvenait
bien février on a cru qu'elle avait
moins de les réhabiliter
alors on s'est pas aussi bien préparés
qu'on allait dessus comment ça va
comment ça se passe vous êtes les
dépanneurs sont des services
essentiellement même temps les stations
service parce que vous offrez beaucoup
de l'essence aussi il ya quand même une
chute des ventes une chute des prix
comment ça se passe comment ça se passe
avec les priorités quand on a mis en
place de la journée
nos employés et nous qui dort déjà
les directives étaient claires info
désinfecter il faut mettre des barrières
de protection avec les plexiglas
on appuie toutes sortes d'initiatives il
faut emballer que ceux des produits par
exemple on a aussi à lancer rapidement
une initiative pour nos employés a
augmenté laissant la deûle à 50 leur
partout en amérique du nord et une
initiative pour les prochains d'alain
présentement dès les premiers tours et
rappelé les policiers les pompiers
demain déjà de la santé ce petit
initiative mais qui signifie beaucoup
pour les jeunes
le café et le thé les breuvages gratuit
est ce qu est ce que le 2 $ 52 plus de
leurs va rester après la crise
non non c'est l'initiative temporaire
jeu pour lui de discussion avec
l'exécutif là dessus mais non ce soit un
coût est énorme pour nous déjà que les
seuls animaux montrent un peu partout a
lancé ce père et pour cpournous
d'absorber tout ça c'est l'ensemble de
l'industrie le feu ne fait pas mais elle
si c'était une démarche d'ensemble ouais
je vous dirais que oui on en ferait
partie
mais évidemment il y aurait des
ajustements aux marges et à notre façon
d'opérer
est-ce que vous opérez à perte en ce
moment alors non on ne perd pas à perte
mais évidemment nous sommes de
l'affecter considérablement ce qui nous
a est présentement c'est une conjoncture
que vous avez mentionné au début la
baisse des volumes c'est énorme
au niveau des naissances mais la marge
est beaucoup plus élevé surtout aux
états-unis au canada la marge de la même
face de la la dynamique est différente
mais aux états unis la marge est plus
élevé alors ce qui nous permet de
compenser en partie et les ventes des
magasins vont bien oui ça va bien donc
dans les magasins parce que tout le
reste est fermé quasiment donc beaucoup
de plus de gens qui vont chez vous nous
voyez trafic moins de clients mais plus
de cheveux les achats sont en plus
grande quantité
ah oui plus grand format et clients
viennent moins souvent mais achètent
plus le président trump a annoncé un
plan de réouverture en trois phases et
je posais la question à monsieur morneau
en début d'émission à savoir si le
canada allait annoncer comme ça un plan
de réouverture
prochainement vous vous en pensez quoi
est-ce qu'il faut rouvrir l'économie se
dépêcher comme on doit faire ça selon
vous pas se dépêcher si on regarde mais
à les modèles de l'économique de
réouverture de l'économie on parlait de
v de vue plus long terme
moi je vois plus je u kfw quoique si ça
la retrouvait une médication rapidement
ce pourrait être relevé mais il faut
ouvrir lentement mais il faut ouvrir
il faut ouvrir normalement là où on a
des indications claires la séance là
vous vous basez sur les des gens qui
conseillent là dessus je pense qu'on
peut ouvrir on peut ouvrir dans
certaines provinces au canada
on peut ouvrir dans certaines régions au
québec
un peu à la fois peut-être pour tout à
la fois d'un même dans les régions mais
on peut ouvrir si on garde tous fermés
plus longtemps en affecte l'économie
plus longtemps on a fait les gens on va
perdre des mes amis entrepreneurs nous
qui sont vraiment au bord du gouffre si
on se loupe pas bientôt ce souci sera
trop tard
d'ailleurs les entrepreneurs qui nous
écoutent et la situation est absolument
terrible
pour pour plusieurs d'entre vous leur
donnez quoi comme conseil écoutez très
difficile présentement de conseiller
dans les conditions actuelles je dirais
essayer de sauver les meubles
essayez de garder les employés et les
payer et ça s'est souvent des bonnes
décisions qu'on prend au tout début nous
on n'a pas fait mises à pied je pense
pas que la nutrition des magasins qu'on
aurait eu les os des roms mais on n'a
pas envie à qui nos gens parce qu'on a
perdu des gens qui ont été un
confinement leur disait de faire quand
des décisions très très difficile
présentement pour sauver les meubles
parce que c'est les prennent pas
malheureusement ils vont attendre à ce
que l'économie vont réouvrir
est ce que vous trouvez en terminant que
le soutien des gouvernements ils
suffisants et appropriés est ce qu'on en
fait assez oui oui je pense que le
gouvernement font très bien
l on va la version de façon jamais vue
auparavant des décisions at il plus ou
moins bien fait mais dans l'ensemble
très très heureux de gouvernement
provincial général même un gouvernement
bis pour dans la province en général
non je pense nos élus travaillent pas et
on fait des efforts exceptionnels on
vous montrait bien travaillé sur une
leçon à tirer tant qu'à moi ce sont pour
nos aînés avec les histoires des ch et
celle des les maisons de retraite un
général et enfin qu'on tire des grandes
leçons soeur je pense que la grande
maladie que l'on a c'est la
centralisation centralisation
malheureusement ce n'est pas un remède
c'est la mallette
quand on donne trop de pouvoir
centralisé d'un des mains qui sont longs
et d'où les évènements se passent au
double
le service est rendu mais bien il arrive
que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
si vous aviez le même fonctionnaire le
les fonctionnaires travaillent
s'entassent en train de critiquer les
personnes
je ne sais que le système là même
fonctionnaire qui prend une décision à
québec ou ailleurs mais qui est
centralisé qui l'on est ou na paul santy
du terrain alors déplacé le mettez leur
responsable de 4 ch et seul terrain ch
donner quoi que ce soit et qui prendra
les décisions qui lui seront confiées au
ministère mais il se rapproche puisque
entourage de la réalité et pourra sentir
ce qu'il faut faire
alors que maintenant c'est tout
centraliser les décisions se prennent
dans des bureaux avec de la bonne foi
mais ils ont pas ce qu'il faut pour
faire les bonnes décisions et sa sortie
ce qui s'est passé si je comprends bien
puisque vous parlez de ça ça vous a
choqué déclaré monsieur pleurer parce
que je trouve ça tellement dur de voir
nos personnes âgées souffrir comme ça
c'est terrible
merci monsieur bouchard merci